a UK government funded organization
which influences political and public
opinion about alleged malign Russian
activities has reacted to a recent leak
of its documents the trove was posted
online by the hacker group Anonymous
last week prompting the integrity
initiative to issue a statement poly
Boko has the details
well integrity initiative has finally
replied it's taken them a while because
the RT first spoke about this story last
week but originally these documents were
leaked at the start of the month and the
statement talks about the organization
itself that it's an international public
program that was set up back in 2015 in
order to counter disinformation and
malign influence and also the fact that
it's funded by the UK Foreign Office or
at least it has been for the past two
years before that its money came from
private grants and in relation to the
leaked documents specifically the group
said that it's a matter of deep regret
that they were stolen take a listen to
what they had to say in more detail
we've not yet had the chance to analyze
all of the documents so cannot say with
confidence whether they're all genuine
or whether they include doctored or
false material although it is clear that
much of the material is dated and was
never used so you can see the group
distancing itself from the leaked
documents there they're saying they're
not sure if they're genuine they haven't
had time to verify whether they're all
real and they also point out that a lot
of the documents contain sensitive
contact details some of people that they
were actually considering getting in
touch with but hadn't got in touch with
they're now faced with the headache of
contacting these people and explaining
about this data breach even though
they'd had essentially nothing to do
with the group so clearly not very happy
about this leak and just to refresh your
memory in regards to the original story
the hacked documents appeared through
the anonymous hacking website they got
their hands on this trove of classified
documents that they say prove that the
UK Foreign Office is funding this sort
of and
rusha campaign and as we saw in the
statement there the group says that its
sole purpose is to counter
disinformation and as a result
inevitably that means dealing with a lot
of stuff to do with Russia where they
claim a lot of disinformation comes from
and just to give you an example of the
sort of campaigns that the group conduct
according to these leaked documents you
may have heard allegations that Russia
has was meddling in the Catalonian
independence referendum for example well
that story may have been helped along by
integrity initiative by this group how
well a journalist affiliated to the
group originally posted that story after
that other mainstream media
organizations started talking about it
as well so that for you is how the
system appears to be working that's just
one example and of course it's all
conducted under the banner of altruism
of saving democratic institutions
preventing the spread of disinformation
and fighting the good fight
you